[Music]
a mama's love
kylie jenner gets emotional over her
two-year-old daughter stormy
the reality star and her mini-me graced
the cover of vogue chuca slovakia's
latest issue
and revealed the photo shoot was shot at
her home on her iphone
so iconic the makeup mogul posted an
adorable behind the scenes look showing
her and stormy cuddled up in bed
together
gushing over her daughter kylie wrote on
instagram
i love this little baby so much i want
to burst
sometimes i just look at her and cry
knowing she will never be the small
ever again who knew something so little
could take up most of your heart
god made no mistakes with you storm baby
okay i love you
the vogue issue was titled bedtime story
with kylie jenner and stormy
fashion photographers luca and
alessandro morelli shared a bts pic of
how they made the photo shoot work
during the coronavirus pandemic
writing so honored during this
incredible moment of global change and
new consciousness awakening to reveal
our social distancing cover
with a kind and beautiful kylie jenner
and the princess stormy webster shot via
facetime
i have bought her every single
outdoor toy you could imagine she has
bouncy houses out there
water toys she's been in the pool every
day i'm just trying to make bitter
little slip and blood i gotta slip
inside it's not here yet though
i got everything i'm just trying to make
she's been outside
every day just living her best life i'm
trying
trying to keep her entertained she has
no idea what's going on
kylie is loving the extra quality time
with stormy while practicing social
distancing
i'm gonna put the chocolates right here
okay okay
okay you can only have three of them i'm
gonna give you three of them but wait
you have to wait till mommy comes back
okay i have to go to the bathroom
last month the reality star put her
daughter to the ultimate test
the candy challenge
when stormy almost went for those m m's
she started singing about patience to
stop herself
[Music]
kylie was super impressed with her
little one's behavior
did you win yeah okay you can have three